we're going to talk to you about what's
going on with seattle we got this story
from town hall seattle moves to abolish
entire police force i noticed that they
added a little editorialization here
insane yeah i mean i would argue that's
a fact
yeah finally some good uh reporting
there you go
they say well it may be time to deploy
the military to seattle after all
because because of what local lawmakers
are doing is nothing because what local
lawmakers are doing is nothing short of
allowing the city to be engulfed in
violence and anarchy
they're moving to abolish the police
it's not defunding
it's a total dissolution non-profit
programs and community-led activities
will replace policing why well according
to the resolution the seattle police
department perpetuates racism and
violence
oh yes and it's a vehicle of white
supremacy it's typical woke nonsense
and it's a cancer that's killing america
so i'll pull up this uh this is tweet
from christopher ruffo
breaking seattle's city council moves to
abolish the entire
police department and replace it with a
civilian-led department of community
safety and violence prevention
oh boy you know what this is this is
like
you've got people ready to stab each
other and someone arguing that a
a calm conversation a glass of hot cocoa
will make everything all better
yeah i see it more like um you have you
have terminal cancer
all right but and chemo we might be able
to help you with chemo
but instead of doing chemo let's just uh
exercise
and and eat healthy that's actually a
really a really good uh point that's
exactly what it is
i know it's uh it's it's the it's the uh
um
steve jobs cure you know he got
pancreatic cancer and he was like i know
i'll eat a bunch of fruit and then he
died
yep well this is what this is you know
what man i'll tell you what
they complain about q and on they
complain about right wing conspiracy
theories and alex jones and they ban
them all
and then they let the left-wing
conspiracy theories run rampant
and this is what you get this is the
crystal healing
uh version of policing it's
they're gonna have people coming out how
much wanna bet
the community led violence prevention
people will be wearing crystals
i i don't know all i know is it just
feels like
every criminal in this country is gonna
be like oh open game
it's open season on seattle wow man time
to go to seattle what are they gonna do
you know send you know let me let's talk
let's talk this out
they had a warlord in in seattle
a warlord and that was with the police
what do you think's gonna happen
when if there's no police there's some
dude in seattle is gonna be like
wow no police he's gonna walk outside
with a gun and go bang bang bang
look at me this is i'm the police
officer in my block now what do you
what are they what are they going to do
with community you know what it really
is the like
it's the it's the the coffee enema fruit
cure for cancer
i'm not making that that's a real thing
that's what i'm saying they they get
it's like they're getting rid of the
medicine for crime and and just going
right to
like what causes crime let's just talk
to everybody it's like well crime's not
going to just disappear
it still exists and in fact criminals
that are there are out in the world
they're going to flock to seattle
because there's no police to stop them
you know or to investigate things that
have actually happened
oh my goodness this website's not
loading all too well but let's see if i
can pull up roofo's
christopher ruffo's thread he says in
the proposed legislation the council
argues that the seattle police
department perpetuates racism and
violence
and upholds white supremacy culture
where are they getting that information
i'm sorry i'm sorry the police have
schedules they work hard
they work before play yep yep that's a
good point they believe in time well
they did they did
they did take that down that map of what
whiteness is
yeah so i maybe they're they were
backtracking yeah but they still believe
that stuff i know they do you're right
they're getting rid of it they realize
regular people thought it was crazy
yep he says the council endorses the
decriminal
decriminalized seattle agenda that would
replace the police force with
culturally relevant expertise rooted in
community connections
housing food security and other basic
needs so socialism
right there yeah huh trauma informed
gender affirming anti-racist praxis
what whoa word selling what
help 9-1-1 i have an emergency what do
you need i need trauma-informed
gender-reforming anti-racist praxis
oh my god they're on our they're on
their way what does that even mean
why why couldn't my my question with all
this stuff why couldn't they just have
introduced all this stuff
with the police like what what is this
like why don't they like community
bringing community together that sounds
great
it's like i mean i don't know about that
last bit but i mean getting rid of
police completely sounds
insane like the beginning of that uh
that article that i was talking about
you ever watched it's always sunny in
philadelphia i've seen a few episodes
yeah there's there's one where
they start taking uh i can't remember
which character it's been a long time
watch but they try to get healthy and so
two of the characters have taken
have been taking a ton of supplements
okay and then one's like
so i think it's dennis is like how are
you feeling and the other character is
like
i've been feeling pretty sick i've been
getting like you know diarrhea a lot
oh that's you're flushing the toxins out
to me i'm so efficient
i haven't taken a dump in in days so
like
the point is they view the police as the
toxins yeah
and i've talked to a lot of people who
believe in like weird hippie
conspiratorial
medicines and stuff okay and their
attitude very much so is like
there's no way to be wrong so in this
regard
it's like no the police man they're the
problem
okay well how are you gonna deal with
this no no you don't understand they are
the problem no matter what you say no
matter what you do
no no no saying that you can never be
wrong is the problem
right that is an issue everyone can be
wrong i
can be wrong i i don't mind being proven
wrong because that makes me realize
that i was wrong and now i can be right
instead i would much
rather be right than wrong my goodness
this is
uh for for uh the people asking a lot of
people were asking what praxis is
i got the definition here it says praxis
is the process by which
a theory lesson or skill is enacted
embodied or realized
cool does that okay does that help i
think i've got i've got to issue a
a a a title correction real quick go on
they move to abolish i think that's
different from votes to abolish
so in all in all fairness i will i will
issue that
live correction right now just in case
because it may actually be
they've proposed the abolishment okay so
it's like what's going on in california
with
um you know affirmative action they
they've
moved to put it on the bill or you know
on the voting pallet so people can vote
for it
so they haven't actually voted to
abolish the police department yet
so right so this is the resolution
they've put forward so far but
they've already expressed they have a
veto proof majority
to to well to put it on the docket no no
the city council is going to confirm it
then however it goes don't don't the
people still vote on it i don't believe
so in minneapolis they didn't oh man i'm
pretty sure the city council just says
like
okay that's scary maybe not i don't know
it could be wrong it's just a calling
card for criminals that want to just go
i mean what are they gonna do it reminds
me it's crazy
the thought of having no police is not a
place i want to live in
it's it's utopian thinking man it's well
they what do they think that everyone's
everyone wants to live peacefully
because that's not the case there's
always going to be people that would
rather just take your stuff than go work
for their own stuff what's that there's
a viral meme about putting the shopping
cart back
it was like yes i remember this yeah
there's like a meme that goes around
where it's basically saying that
the shopping cart is the true test for a
civilization yep because
you're you're rewarded nothing for doing
it it's not so
you go to this you go to the store
you're shopping cart you go to your car
you load your car up
and then there's the the cart corral and
cars down
you look at your cart and you look at
the corral and then you kick the cart
and it just goes off
and crashes somewhere and you get your
car and you leave yeah that's the point
it's like
you could very easily just do the little
bit of extra work to put the card away
yeah yet still the parking lot is
littered with carts yeah
people people like to compare to us to
sweden and like you know talk about
sweden it's like
i've been shop i've been to grocery
stores in sweden not
one cart is out out into the anywhere
they all go back to the same spot in the
spot it's just like
there's a general respect for society
well that doesn't exist here
and they're trying to make a socialist
you know city work
well that doesn't work if you know that
everyone isn't in on the same page
exactly that's the grand experiment yeah
sweden
has they've got border restrictions to
varying degrees
i'd imagine yeah in some senses when i
was trying to go from denmark to sweden
years ago
they stopped and checked my passport
yeah they do that still yeah yeah
and i also imagine if you flew in there
they'd stop and check your passport
yep right which means they keep some
people out imagine
i'm sure they do yeah so if if you live
in the united states
and you you you don't live in seattle
and they announced they're giving away
free stuff and there's no police
what's to stop you from flying 4 000
miles from
you know for the furthest point in the
states all the way to this other place
you've never been to you don't know
anybody you're not a part of the
community to get that free stuff well i
mean i
think about the homeless problem in
america which is is a problem there
there are many hopeless homeless people
in many cities why wouldn't they want to
go to seattle then
they do i know they love that's my point
man there's uh
rail i met i i briefly lived in seattle
i knew a bunch of these rail hopper
dudes
okay so they would hop the freight
trains and ride through the country to
various areas where they knew they would
get free stuff
well seattle's uh very quickly going to
become a hot spot
for exactly that what did they do within
three days they were like all of our
food got taken from the homeless people
that
bombarded our country that was real i
thought that was a you don't think that
was real
i mean the the the the the uh
the over-the-top tweet okay was i
believe not real
i believe they did have serious problems
i think so too and then look in new york
look at the new york chaz that happened
why did he take it down his exact words
were
it's more homeless people than
protesters the new york times said that
it's the homeless camp now because the
activists left and the homeless took
over and it's just
it's just homeless people so the city of
seattle is doomed
that's i don't know that's all i see now
there's there's a there was there's also
a homeless camp in philadelphia that was
set up as like a chaz
okay kind of thing and then the homeless
came in and they were like well we're
not leaving until they all get houses
yeah something like that like places to
live but
with what's going on in seattle we're
gonna see this
i i'm willing to bet we're gonna see it
everywhere and it's funny how they
desperately tried to have
you know joe biden is trying so hard to
be both
the i'm not for defunding the police and
i
am by using duplicitous language
like like a true democrat should we
reallocate funds away from police yes
absolutely
should we defund the police well joe
biden never said that
you're alright you're right you're
literally correct he didn't literally
say that
but he explained what defund the police
was well i mean they're actually
abolishing it here
and there's that's the plan anyway i
guess right and i wanna i wanna show you
a picture that exemplifies why that's so
amazing
it's a picture of a bunch of explosives
huh
mayor jenny durkin is asking for peace
and an end to violence and vandalism
this does not get us closer to justice
i'm i'm sorry man
at this point i just got to say i've i
have no sympathy for people who live in
seattle
i think i have a theory if you'll bear
with me yes what is the theory so i
think the common thread that runs
through this utopian ideal
is the idea that people are basically
good and that you can talk them out of
crime
and i don't think it's true i don't
think people are basically good i think
it's a russoin idea
that has been disproven a long time ago
it's not
culture that makes people bad people are
generally not good
no i i disagree i think i think the the
general amount of people are good
but in places like this the people that
aren't good
are going to flock there that that it's
it's like a a
moth to the flame it's it's the open
season on this area because
there's no cops so i can't get in
trouble if i go do some crime there
you know and rob people or you know
whatever i want to do
but the fact that the criminals are out
there and that they're planning on
coming there
is and and seattle thinks that they can
just kind of talk them out of it
is just kind of idealistic to me yeah
that's true it's not
saying that most people are not good i i
will never agree with that
well i i don't think it's a matter of
good or evil i think it's a matter of
survival okay you know do you see that
i'm not gonna blame the lion for eating
a gazelle
like that evil lion just killed that
gazelle yeah but that's that's
that's not really comparable i mean we
we are humans we we know
we're the ones who declare what good and
bad is so
a lion eating killing and eating a
gazelle is just the natural process
that lion's not and i'm killing this
gazelle and and taking its wallet
and killing it to eat it because it's
natural and when somebody
takes advantage of another person to
enrich themselves or better you know
you know strength like to to give
themselves access to resources or power
yeah or to benefit it is it is someone
you know preying upon somebody else so
it's it's an issue of
good or bad it's an issue of stability
access to resources
but there are even people who don't need
things who would still you know
target assault steal rob or otherwise
the what we're seeing here with like
seattle is
you've got a hen house you've got foxes
running around
and they're like maybe if we open the
door and let the foxes in
everything will be all right sure so
it's it's like
great have fun with that right right i
think it's it's fair to say because
we're humans we have a perspective on
what we think
is like appropriate human behavior like
if a dude comes in
and robs a bank that's bad obviously you
know
so the issue is that person is you know
seeking to
you know ransack and steal and loot do
we open the door for them or do we
put guards in front of it and say sorry
bro you can't come in here and steal our
money from our bank well that's the
messed up part because that's not even
what cops do
oh what cops do are at are posted at
banks but for the most part they
they show up after the fact to like see
what happened and
they're not they're not there to prevent
crime i mean in a sense they are because
their simple presence stops
people from doing it because they know
that they're there and they will get in
trouble for it so what do you think
happens
when you repeatedly tell people of low
cognitive function
that all police are bad and that all
they do
is violently beat random people and then
these people come to believe it
i will tell you something i have a tweet
for all of you i believe this tweet
shows an example of
people who clearly don't know what it is
police do
yep here's the tweet from a twitter user
with the name
abolish police i was just assaulted by
this man on sunrise and gold center
he tried to break my car window grabbed
me out of the car
hit me and spit on me he followed me to
my work and threatened to kill me
please help me identify him so i can
press charges and file a restraining
order
gee i wonder who will enforce such
orders
and and help you file such charges
that's embarrassing it's it's kind of
like you were saying about getting rid
of chemo but it's it's actually more
interesting than that
it would be like walking into a into a
hospital
and complaining about one doctor who's
got a malpractice lawsuit and demanding
we abolish
all hospitals yep it's like this
hospital service you know our hospitals
across this country
service millions upon millions of
individuals
every single month across the country
and there were nine instances where a
doctor accidentally dropped a junior
mint
into a person while he was getting
surgery abolish all hospitals
abolish all doctors all of them gotta go
hey hold on
have you ever has that happened the
finger meant thing yeah seinfeld
okay yeah yeah it was a great reference
though
do you know the episode no like kramer
is like looking down and he's eating
junior mints and then everyone
falls and they're up on the like the
yeah right
oh no how stupid does that sound we must
get good
now hold on now hold on now what if
someone said you know what
we do have doctors now here's what it
really does get interesting
we have doctors that provide service to
millions upon millions of people per
month
you know i don't even know how many
people per year actually go you know go
see doctors
who knows would it be crazy to call for
medical reform
because nine people had botched
surgeries and died
nope i don't think so i agree so i don't
think so
uh like what are we do i mean actually i
think a review might make sense like
well nine people shouldn't have died we
should review those cases and figure out
how to make sure that doesn't happen
ever again
they do right news flash they do
even for even and and to bring it back
to the what you're actually talking
about
even the cops that do that they do that
there is a review so that actually
happens already
so you know that you know the problem
ends up becoming there are absolutely
instances where police abuse their power
okay chicago i was reading this story
from fox 32.
one of their units was literally
committing home invasions they disbanded
the unit
that's the least they could have done
right so the problems exist and there
are dirty doctors
you know they issue fake prescriptions
they get people hooked on opiates all
that stuff they get arrested
it's already illegal yeah now i
understand in this analogy the challenge
is that who police is the police right
you've got internal affairs
and there's still politics involved so
there can be some challenges that i get
and the fact that like a bad cop can get
fired and just go
four counties down get a job at a
different place and they'll take them on
like
oh you're a cop all right cool no
worries we got you that's arguably true
for any industry
that's a good point like journalists
well i mean that's an issue though that
that's something that we
we should look at and that does need to
be changed a journalist
a journalist say let's say
hypothetically there was a guy who
worked for buzzfeed news
and he wrote a bunch of fake stories
about people associated with
anti you know sjws anti-feminism or or
uh you know conservatism
and he lied about them left and right to
damage their careers and get him banned
from
youtube then imagine he got hired by the
financial times
and was caught spying on another
newsroom and got and was forced to
resign over it yep
a guy like that could simply go to
another outlet and find a new job
that's that's that's a real story sure
could you actually guy did that we see
it all the time
so are we going to call for a journalism
reform now not one journalist will i
guarantee you that i would love
i would love a journalist reform i would
love some sort of
something to curb them in i know we talk
about it freedom of speech like they can
people need to choose who they listen to
it's also private industry
yeah yeah so i don't know how you how
you actually do that stuff but i will
point out
if we think that there's going to be a
certain margin
margin of failure for any industry even
police
the problem becomes what's what's
appropriate you know if
one person out of the 300 million
interactions with police
dies because a cop did wrong do we need
to abolish all of the police
no that's literally insane
do we need police reform i mean if
there's one guy i
know i think we arrest the cop who
abused his power and killed a guy
you know maybe and and we do an internal
review as to how it happened and try and
make sure it doesn't happen again yeah
but what happens when you end up with
something like ferguson hands up don't
shoot where it literally turns out never
happened
yeah what happens when you get people
who riot for for actual
criminals which has happened all the
time you know they talk about black
lives matter but one thing that often
doesn't get brought up is that although
we can agree that george floyd shouldn't
have died what about the people in in
seattle
i'm not saying i'm sorry st louis and
other places not michael brown there
were other people
who in milwaukee for instance who
actually had guns
actually shot at cops and then got you
know killed in self-defense
they still riot for these people yeah i
don't care so i'll tell you what's going
on right now
you'd think portland was over right it's
not you know why
what do you think the activists are
saying now
at first it was defund the police get
the feds out of there
all right free the protesters and ted
wheeler resign those were the demands
okay so here's what happens the feds
stay in the courthouse because oregon
deployed state
law enforcement into the courthouse as
well and then
activists stopped antifa from throwing
explosives
that's all everything according to the
guardian and a couple other outlets
that's what went down last night
so now what are the activists
demanding are they leaving why aren't
they leaving they won
they're saying we still haven't brought
those officers to justice yet
that's right there is the ones that were
rightfully holding
back the riders from the courthouse down
is that who they're talking about do
they even know they're talking i don't
let's just say yes okay and so the issue
then becomes
no matter what happens they will keep
saying we haven't got our demands yet
yep
so it's like here you go i just want to
burn the courthouse down that's it they
want to burn whatever evidence
is in there i'm just convinced of it now
i think they just want to break stuff
i think they can break anything they're
focused on the courthouse
why there's something in there they want
trump
it's a symbol of trump fed the feds but
now it's
now it's not the feds and all of a
sudden they're not throwing firebombs
anymore good point
yep the state police came in oh we can't
have them claiming the democrat secret
police are oppressing us
so all of a sudden the protesters
stopped antifa from throwing explosives
but they allowed it when it was the feds
that's the point yeah it's a symbol
they're attacking they're angry it makes
no sense
and as soon as they can find some kind
of political advantage they're like
everybody calm down everybody calm down
we don't want trump to look good anymore
because he was
so now in an interview with the
oregonian they asked the protesters like
what's going on and they said we can't
leave until these officers are held
accountable
it's like oh okay so it's never going to
stop never
it's going to be this way until the
election i guess yeah that's that's the
perfect
getaway for them it's like because the
cops weren't doing anything wrong they
were
holding people back from burning the
courthouse down
so now they're like well now we can just
be mad forever
and we can just riot and continue let's
talk about what it is police do
okay sure in the context of doctors
do you go to a doctor and then he says
like i'm going to give you medicine and
you'll never get cancer
that's a ridiculous analogy but yes with
vaccines i'm going to give you this
medicine and it will prevent you from
getting this disease there's
preventative actions
true okay by doctors now with the police
is there preventative action there
actually is in a sense yeah for sure
the fact that cops are patrolling is in
fact a deterrent especially if cops are
actively patrolling areas like
they do this in new york they'll go into
certain neighborhoods whether you like
it or not
and that can act as a deterrent the same
thing is true in chicago
then what do they do after you've been
the victim of a crime
they seek to remedy it i actually find
that a lot of
in a lot of circumstances i have not had
good luck with cops remedying serious
crimes
and i don't even know how you how like
how how you actually get someone in
trouble for
like i don't know non-violent crimes
like like financial crimes
is beyond me i had a landlord once steal
a
uh a check out of my trash can and
forged my signature whoa
and when i went to the police they were
like we're not gonna do anything about
that what
yup how wow like that's that's a felony
isn't it
serious seriously yeah whoa so the
problem was that
i was so i wrote a check for rent but
i'd never signed it okay
because i was going to be traveling so i
pre-wrote two months in advance okay
but then they told us we had to move out
because they were reclaiming the
property the landlords
okay so i had my checkbook and i just
threw the checks in the trash
and i've tied the trash up and then i
forgot to take it out
one day i look and there's a cash check
in my bank account
and it's clearly not my signature on it
wow
so i called my bank and they said if you
want the money back we can do that but
you have to
file a police report so i walked to the
local police
and they said no we can't handle that
because this is the wrong department you
got to go to this department
so i walked to the next apartment and
they said what are you talking about
we're not even in your your neighborhood
you got to go back to the other
department
so now i got mad i go back to the other
one and i actually started screaming
at them i was like i want to press
charges
i want my money back my bank will give
to me unless you guys file this report
and then finally a supervisor came out
and said fine fine fill this out
here you go and that was it they never
did anything about it wow but i did get
my money back
all right so anyway the point is yeah a
lot of people get mad about that stuff
too
i'm still not stupid enough to say
abolish all of the police yeah yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next
episode